plus friday night isn't enough time for
the nfl
to be sure that the outbreak is
contained that is the fundamental
difference and
you know i saw a lot of people
complaining right out of the gates that
the raiders didn't get this
consideration the 49ers didn't get this
consideration this wasn't
about roger goodell deciding to give the
ravens a break
because the ravens are going to be
short-handed
with bodies the next man up approach is
going to apply
when it can in this case and the nfl has
given me the statement having a chance
to post it yet on twitter but in this
case
and here's the quote directly from the
league this is an ongoing matter with
new positives among players and staff
there have been a total of seven player
positive and additional personnel cases
in the last three days
delaying several days gives us more
testing time
and provides greater comfort and
certainty than playing tomorrow
when there could be additional issues
that affect could affect both the ravens
and the steelers and the rest of their
stevens so you know there's been some
cynicism about the nfl saying we're
making player health and safety the
paramount concern this is the
prime example of the fact that they are
because the thursday night game
thanksgiving night game one of the
marquee games of the year
sacrificed because of this and
the the the perception created
incorrect as it may be that the nfl is
being wishy-washy about when and where
it will pull the plug on a game
again this isn't about helping the
ravens this is about ensuring
that the outbreak is contained and i'm
told they won't know until friday
if it's contained and if it's not
contained as a friday
this 1 15 p.m eastern game on sunday is
not set in stone
that game may end up being the first one
to be kicked to what would be an 18th
week shireen
of the 2020 regular season because as
you said next thursday night
cowboys at ravens unless you're going to
move that game too
you can't expect the ravens to play
monday or tuesday so it's going to be
sunday at 1 15 p.m eastern or
raven steelers the first game for week
18
meaning that maybe the ravens end up
being the team
that has the last best chance of keeping
the steelers from going 16-0
yeah and i understand why the steelers
are upset mike twice now
you know they had the first time they
had their bye week moved and now they're
having this game moved and they're on a
roll and
feel like they're playing well and they
were looking forward to having that that
mini buy that they were going to get
and now they're not going to have that
many buy so i get it and and the
steelers have done a great job of
keeping covid
for the most part out of their facility
they haven't had the covid problems that
other teams have had they haven't had
the injury problems frankly that other
teams have had
they've been relatively healthy they've
been relatively covet-free
and now they get you know another uh
setback here with the schedule makers
but that's the way it goes
and we knew this season wasn't going to
be normal
and it's not normal and you have to play
the hands down you and this is the hand
they're dealt
deal with it go win a game on sunday and
keep your winning streak going that'd be
11 in a row
yeah that's and i agree with what you
said at the end i think it's a bad look
frankly and i've been on the steelers
bandwagon all year and it's great to see
them 10-0 for the first time in their
history i'd like to think that if mike
tomlin had
realized what was about to transpire he
would have told his guys
don't go complaining on social media
about this our attitude is
we'll play whenever wherever however you
want us to show up at the parking lot of
the walmart on black friday
we'll do it then we'll play whenever you
want us to play
we understand there's a bigger picture
here we understand there's broader
concerns
that will dictate the possibility of
games being moved and sometimes that may
be an inconvenience for us but that's
fine
i mean that was his attitude back when
they lost their bye week
so i get it that the players are going
to want to vent this is one of the
problems with social media you can pick
up that cell phone device you can punch
in whatever you want to punch in
and get that out of your system and then
maybe when the dust settles you think
you know
i get it i understand why they did what
they did and that's not the look that we
want to generate as a team that aspires
to be 16-0
and has an attitude of we'll play you
anytime anyplace anywhere so
i think that part of it while
understandable was unfortunate and
my guess is with all the crap that was
going on
mike tomlin didn't have a chance to make
it known to his players
let's not vent on social media about
this
we need to project strength and
confidence
and a flexibility to play whenever they
tell us we're going to play
yeah and they're the best team in the
nfl mike and and they can go prove that
again sunday and it's not like the
ravens are magically going to get all
these players back that they have on
covet lists and we know there's some
huge
names on this covet list that they're
going to be with that on sunday so it's
not like it's a benefit to the ravens to
get all these players back they're not
going to get
most of these players back because most
of them tested positive it wasn't a
close contact situation
so they're still going to have the
advantage on sunday they still should go
out and win that game they're going to
be favored
go get it done you're not going to have
your mini buy that's the way it goes
move on it's almost the end of the
season anyway and get ready for the
playoffs and
and get in the playoffs they hope with
the 16-0 record
yeah i i think that they'll still be
fine come sunday as you said the ravens
are still
disadvantaged by the entire situation
far more so than the pittsburgh steelers
and
this is just another reminder to all the
nfl players and coaches out there that
this is a critical time and you know to
the extent that
someone argued i think it was mark
cabola of the athletic that if the
ravens aren't able to go on sunday it
should be a forfeit
the nfl is not going to have any
forfeits this year
because if you forfeit a game the
argument can strongly be made by the nfl
players association that you have to pay
the players it goes in the books as a
two-nothing victory
by the team that didn't forfeit the nfl
has
not addressed that that's not
contemplated in the agreement that was
reached back in late july to allow the
season to go forward
the players don't get paid if games are
cancelled or suspended
and that's what ultimately would happen
if they can't make this up
week 18 so if you're a steelers player
you got to realize hey at the end of the
day my
game check may be riding on this and
maybe it's an inconvenience
and maybe we'll lose maybe we won't be
as rested the following week because we
don't have our mini buy on the back end
but if they can't play the game sunday
and if for some reason they can't make
it up later all those guys whose tweets
you saw
complaining about the game being
postponed
they're not going to get paid they're
not going to get paid for this game
so that's the other side of this as well
and it's amazing how quickly shireen
the mood will turn i mean we've been
praising the nfl we got through
the first 11 weeks of the season with
all games being played
i thought the problems would come a week
or two from now
after we do this massive mini
super spreader everyone flying around
the country and going into their little
abodes for the holiday and then taking
it back to wherever they came from and
passing through hotels and
and airports and sitting on planes and i
i think that
that the nfl may have far bigger
problems
than the ravens come one week or two
weeks from now and the other side of it
too
i don't know that you could fault the
ravens for this see if the nfl's
attitude
is going to be we're sending everyone
home
out into the community after every day
of work after every game and we
understand that guys are gonna get
positive
okay you understand they're gonna get
positive how
how can you fault a team if
you have created a system premised on
we know guys are going to get it and our
goal is to intercept
and and keep it from becoming an
outbreak now there may be more to it
when you consider the raw number of
ravens that got it but
but you know what if it was as simple as
the doughnut hole that we've talked
about all year
test samples collected on sunday morning
of mark
ingram and jk dobbins you don't find out
until monday morning that they have it
all day long around their teammates in
the locker room
on the sideline and it just so happened
that it spread to a bunch of other guys
and it's popping up as the week unfolds
so
i just think it's a dangerous precedent
to set at a time when the nfl seems to
be
more concerned than anything else about
just
getting the games in and not pointing
fingers
at teams who clearly want to get the
games in but
as long as people are going home every
night you're going to have inevitable
positives and the way that the system is
set up you're going to have inevitable
spread within a team
well and mike that's when we saw the
memo come out this week too
you know more masks on the sidelines and
all of those sorts of things that
they're going to have
now uh getting more people out of the
building who are in the building who are
unnecessary to have in the building
they're doing every step they can take
to to minimize this but look
kovit's going to win guys are going to
come down with covet it's all about risk
mitigation and that's what they've said
all along so they're doing the best they
can there if they didn't
penalize the titans way back when
they're not going to penalize any team
uh for this well they did but they did
they got it for 350 000.
okay well they they hit them yeah they
did finally penalize them yes yes yes
they did
but that was the first one we saw really
of a team that that didn't do the right
things and they did penalize them
uh some so you know they want to get
these games in they're going to do it
however they can and they're going to
try to keep guys healthy but
when they're out in their communities
unless they have the bubble you know
kids are going to school and coming home
and
and bringing it home to them and and the
guys are around other people and it is
spreading
it's a community spread it's not within
a team as much as a community spread and
bringing it into the locker room and
they hope there that they can keep it
from spreading a lot but we've seen with
the ravens
it spread they didn't know the doughnut
hole was there
and shireen what still bothers me the
most about this
that that game of poker
that the nfl and the nflpa are still
playing about
the localized home market bubbles the
nfl doesn't want to ask for it because
they'd have to make a concession to the
union
it's a significant ask to tell guys to
leave their homes and leave their
families for the rest of the season
the union doesn't want to offer it even
though they recognize
that individual game checks hang in the
balance if games have to be canceled
the union has believed all year long the
nfl will move heaven and earth to get
those games in so they continue
to have this awkward and bizarre stare
down
and it's going to take i think a
significant development
to get the union and the league to
finally say let's just put everybody
into a hotel
it's the only way that we're going to
keep this from getting worse
instead of better